la tension monte d'un cran en birmanie
dans les rues de mende à l'oeil la
deuxième ville du pays
les tirs des forces de sécurité envers
les manifestants ont eu des conséquences
dramatiques
bilan deux morts et une trentaine de
blessés ils ont battu et tué mon mari et
d'autres personnes qui se tenait à côté
et regarder la manifestation mais les
soldats l'ont emmené des violences
immédiatement qualifiée d'inacceptable
par une partie de la communauté
internationale
je condamne fermement la violence contre
des manifestants civils pacifiques par
les militaires j'exhorte l'armée et
toutes les forces de sécurité en
birmanie à mettre fin immédiatement aux
violences contre les civils
nous discuterons lundi des derniers
événements birmanie pour prendre les
décisions appropriées
je condamne le recours à la violence
mortelle en birmanie
le recours à la force meurtrière à
l'intimidation et au harcèlement contre
des manifestants pacifiques est
inacceptable
tout le monde a le droit de se réunir
pacifiquement j'appelle toutes les
parties à respecter les résultats des
élections et à revenir à un régime civil
depuis le 1er février et le coup d'état
militaire contre le gouvernement donc
sommes succi la vague de contestation se
poursuivre malgré la répression
ils étaient ce samedi encore des
milliers dans les rues de rangoon la
capitale économique du pays
ala militaires ont déclaré qu'il
gouvernait de manière démocratique mais
en même temps ils ont immédiatement
coupé la connexion internet est bloqué
les réseaux sociaux comme facebook et
twitter
ça signifie que leurs paroles ne
correspond pas à leurs actes donc on ne
parlera jamais si longtemps
on ne peut pas accepter la répression
policière parce qu'elle est indiscipliné
au delà des lois
je suis vraiment désolé de voir que
certains manifestants ont été attaqués
même s'ils ne sont pas de ma famille
malgré les multiples condamnations de la
communauté internationale et de
plusieurs ong
le pouvoir militaire reste pour le
moment sourd aux appels à la désescalade